can Tom Cruise really sing uh well yeah  I mean I did all My Singing in Rock of  Ages  [Music]  yes I sing I Need Your Love Can Tom  Cruise rock climb yes I trained for many  years actually  Ken Tom Cruise play guitar  I definitely need more practice but I  enjoy playing guitar can Tom Cruise fly  a plane yes  yes I fly uh airplanes I'm a  multi-engine instrument rated commercial  pilot okay James I'm just gonna try  something here just hang on  and Tom Cruise hold his breath for six  minutes yes I can hold my breath for six  minutes uh  can Tom Cruise fly a helicopter yes uh  again I fly a helicopter I fly a  robotics in that and uh commercially  rated helicopter Pilots